I just did a parasite test kit by the batting system seems to get backed up when detoxing
just doing my normal protocol for cancer.
What is your thoughts on doing a parasite cleanse if they determine I have them?
I feel like I don't feel good more than I feel good, especially with swollen lips in my neck
and sore throat.
So we talk about parasites, it gets a little tricky, because most functional medicine doctors
and certainly all regular medical doctors, if they see a parasite test, they think,
oh my gosh, we got to kill them, you know, there's parasites, oh my God, that's horrible,
we got to kill those parasites.
But there's a whole other light of thinking.
So yes, access parasites in your body can cause issues where your immune system is fighting
a battle at multiple fields, and in one sense it does make sense to kill parasites.
But in another sense, you have to understand that even parasites can have a symbiotic relationship
in your body, leading that they aren't necessarily doing damage all the time.
And if you're going to try to do a big parasite cleanse and flush using things like wormwood
and olive leaf extract and different herbal things like that, well, those are good and
that can be great.
You have to look at, am I healthy enough to do that?
Is it going to be poor or conned to me?
The best thing to do, honestly, I know this isn't a great, you know, yes or no answer, but
the best thing to do is you can try things.
So there are some parasite protocols with biocided and cell core products that you could use to,
you know, you could even pulse them instead of doing a, like I'm going to do this 21 day
parasite cleanse, you could go, I'm going to do, you know, maybe every other day with this.
So I'm going to do every third day with this.
And see if it makes you worse, let me take a step back.
Many people with cancer, you know, you're solely focused on the cancer.
But we ignore sometimes the possibility and the real likeness that we also have comorbidities.
But we also have other things going on.
And the most common thing that we have going on that we see throughout society is a comorbidity
of autoimmune disease.
You have an autoimmune secondary, maybe even primary to the cancer condition going on.
You have antibodies to self tissue.
That's why my autoimmune course really what let's I get done.
Everybody, all my cancer members to go through it because you're going to find that there's a lot of ties that tie in with cancer
and autoimmune disorders.
So what is an autoimmune disorder?
It's when you have antibodies to self tissue, any self tissue that you have antibodies to.
And then there's different levels of autoimmune disorders.
It can be in a latent level where it's not really causing symptoms to, you know, a tissue destructive level.
Where you see, you know, damage to bolder, you have damage to the tissue itself.
And then the middle level is where you have the symptoms, but not huge amounts of tissue destruction.
A lot of people are in that second level where you have symptoms of that.
And many times we are blaming cancer for some of the symptoms that we may be experiencing that are really autoimmune related.
The reason I'm talking about it with the question about parasites is that when you have an autoimmune issue
and you're going to go after killing a parasite, that can flare an autoimmune issue.
So typically, trying to kill a parasite with some of the nutritional things that I talked about a couple of minutes ago,
if you solely have cancer, there's really no harm to follow.
It's not going to hurt your cancer by using some of those parasite killing parasite cleansing nutrients
or even a parasite killing medication could actually help the, kill the cancer in the case of like Ivermectated, Fedbedozole and things like that.
But if you have an autoimmune disease, cold morbidity, then you could actually flare that and become worse.
That's why I said, even if your parasite test comes back positive, I would still maybe go slow with the treatment
because if you have a cold morbid autoimmune disorder, you could get worse.
That, in fact, some autoimmune patients do better when they have a parasite, which is a total flipflop of understanding.
There is actually a treatment for autoimmune disease that's called
a health-synth treatment, where you actually get a bottle of these parasite eggs, and you take that once a week.
Yeah, crazy.
So you're actually inoculating yourself with parasites, and in doing so, it causes an immune reaction in the gut and it takes the
immune reaction away from the autoimmune site.
Let's say if it's thyroid or if it's a lupus or an MS, and it really has helped a lot of MS patients.
So don't take it too off of that subject, but we've got to keep it balanced that
just because I have this doesn't mean I have to kill it, there could be negatives to it as well.